les maisons ravagées par les flammes se
consume lentement sous les yeux dépités
de leurs propriétaires pour ses
habitants d'un petit village du haut
karabagh c'est désormais la politique de
la terre brûlée
quitte à incendier leurs propres
demeures ou à utiliser des bulldozer car
ces arméniens n'ont plus le choix
leur district celui d'acs dame doit
repasser ce souveraineté azerbaïdjanaise
au plus tard ce vendredi
selon l'accord de paix signé sous
l'égide de la russie pourquoi devrais je
l'abandonné gelé presque terminée nous
la construisons depuis dix ans j'ai été
déplacée de karni roval où vivent
maintenant des azéri c'est désormais la
troisième maison que je me suis mise à
construire et encore une fois je n'ai
pas de chance c'est dans ce contexte que
les forces de maintien de la paix
envoyés par moscou se déploie pour
assurer le respect du cessez le feu
leur corridor humanitaire a déjà permis
à plus de 3000 personnes de retourner à
stepanakert la capitale du haut karabagh
beaucoup de ces réfugiés sont désormais
désoeuvrés il nous disait venez venez la
dernière fois ils nous ont amené la nuit
ils nous ont abandonnés à gori ce milieu
de la route toute la nuit ils nous ont
amenés ici et nous ont abandonnés
personne ne se soucie de nous nous
sommes arrivés ici mais comment pouvons
nous vivre
nous n'avons pas un sou que devrions
nous faire
oui c'est vrai il nous donne quelque
chose qu'on peut manger
mais que ferons nous demande il faut
avoir de l'argent pour acheter des
vêtements c'est l'hiver nous avons tout
laissé dans notre village nous sommes
partis la situation dans le haut
karabagh est également suivie avec
attention par l'union européenne
bruxelles a salué la cessation des
hostilités mais réclame une enquête sur
des crimes de guerre supposés de son
côté la russie assure travailler en
collaboration avec le groupe de minsk
qui supervise la situation dans la
région
nous avons eu une
réunion spéciale avec les représentants
des états unis et de la france
ils sont venus à moscou il me semble que
ces représentants spéciaux de paris et
de washington pour le haut karabagh qui
travaille avec notre représentant
spécial ont pleinement accepté nos
renseignements complémentaires au total
l'accord de paix signé entre azéri et
arménien octroie à bas coût la reprise
de trois districts d'ici au 1er décembre
l'azerbaïdjan reconquiert ainsi de
larges territoires qui étaient passés
sous contrôle arménien depuis près de 30
ans